This is not 99% invisible, but I am Roman Mars. Dear Hank and John is a podcast where two brothers, Hank Green and John Green, answer questions and give dubious advice. And if I am in a car with my kids, it is the thing we are listening to. I love it, I learn a lot, it makes me laugh, it gets my kids talking, which is amazing. Last year I finagled my way onto the show and podcasted with the best-selling author YouTuber, podcaster, educator, and marvelous human Hank Green, and we had an excellent time answering questions about chickens and space and other sundry topics.
这不是《99%无形》，但我依然是罗曼·马尔斯。《亲爱的汉克与约翰》是一档播客，由汉克·格林和约翰·格林这两兄弟回答问题并提供一些不靠谱的建议。如果我和孩子们在车里，我们听的就是这个。我非常喜欢它，我学到了很多，它让我发笑，还能让我的孩子们参与讨论，这太棒了。去年，我设法参加了这档节目，并与这位畅销书作家、YouTuber、播客主、教育家和了不起的人——汉克·格林一起录制了节目，我们非常愉快地讨论了关于鸡、太空以及其他各种各样的话题。
I am delighted to say that I had the opportunity to return to the show this week, but this time I was paired with the best-selling author, YouTuber, podcaster, educator, and marvelous human, John Green. His other podcast, and most recent book is called The Anthropocene Reviewed. It is everything I love about everything. If you like 90-IPI, you will love The Anthropocene Reviewed. But in the meantime, here's me guest hosting Dear Hank and John, with John Green. Enjoy. Hello and welcome to Dear Hank and John, or as I prefer to think of it, dear John and Roman Mars, that's right. It's a podcast where John, your second favorite green brother, is joined by your very favorite podcast host, Roman Mars, to answer your questions,
我很高兴地说，本周我有机会再次回到节目中，但这次我的搭档是畅销书作家、YouTuber、播客主、教育家和了不起的人——约翰·格林。他的另一个播客以及最近出版的书叫《人类世评论》。它包含了所有我热爱的一切。如果你喜欢《99%无形》，你也会喜欢《人类世评论》。但在此期间，这是我作为客座主持与约翰·格林共同录制的《亲爱的汉克与约翰》。请欣赏。你好，欢迎收听《亲爱的汉克与约翰》，或者我更愿意称之为《亲爱的约翰与罗曼·马尔斯》，没错。这是一档播客，约翰，也就是你第二喜欢的格林兄弟，将与你最喜欢的播客主持人罗曼·马尔斯一起，回答你们的问题，
give you Dubies Advice and bring you all the weeks news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon. Roman, you're the host of 99% Invisible. One of my favorite podcasts of all time. Oh, thank you. How come you keep coming on dear Hank and John? Yeah. Because this is one of my favorite podcasts of all time.
为你提供不靠谱的建议，并为你带来本周来自火星和温布尔登竞技足球俱乐部的新闻。罗曼，你是《99%无形》的主持人。这是我最喜欢的播客之一。哦，谢谢。你为什么一直来参加《亲爱的汉克与约翰》？是的，因为这是我最喜欢的播客之一。
This is my family's podcast. Like so, the twins, when I have them in the car, we pull up to Dear Hank and John. And when the question comes up, they know I hate it when people talk over the podcasts. So they reach forward, because I can't listen to two things at once. I've gotten old, you know, like I, and they reach forward, they reach forward and they hit pause on the little
这是我家庭的播客。就像这样，双胞胎在车里时，我们会打开《亲爱的汉克与约翰》。当问题出现时，他们知道我讨厌别人在播客播放时说话。所以他们会向前探身，因为我无法同时听两件事。我老了，你知道，我……他们会向前探身，按下那个小控制台上的暂停键。
console. And they'll answer the question before you have a chance to answer it. And they go, I think I know this. And then, and this is just a part of our life. So, so dear Hank, Thomas is very important to me. So I'm really honored to be here. Well, we are thrilled that you're here. The last time you were here, and we don't usually bring this kind of thing up at the beginning of the podcast, but something extraordinary has happened that I need to inform you about. The last time you were here, you and Hank were chatting about remind me exactly what it was. It was how many chickens would need to be in space
然后他们会在你有机会回答之前就抢着回答。他们会说：“我想我知道这个。”然后，这已经成了我们生活的一部分。所以，《亲爱的汉克与约翰》对我来说非常重要。所以我真的很荣幸能来到这里。嗯，我们很高兴你能来。你上次来的时候，虽然我们通常不在节目开头提这种事，但发生了一件非同寻常的事，我需要告诉你。你上次来的时候，你和汉克在聊——提醒我一下具体是什么。是关于太空中需要有多少只鸡，
before humans would notice. Is that correct? I think it was something like that. Like I don't recall it. Perfectly, great. So we have received the following email from Rachel that I simply cannot wait to tell you about. Dear John and Hank, here in the astronomy community,
人类才会注意到。是这样吗？我想大概是这样。我不记得了。太棒了。所以我们收到了瑞秋发来的以下邮件，我简直迫不及待想告诉你。亲爱的约翰和汉克，在天文学界，
we take two things very seriously, knowing everything that is in space and April Fool's Day. For this April Fool's Day, I roped a postdoc friend of mine into doing some math in order to answer the question that Hank and Roman Mars recently examined. How many chickens would there need to be in space before we would notice? This resulted in a scientific paper, Roman, called Nuggets of Wisdom, which is a good point. There's a lot of good puns in this paper, but I would just like to read you one sentence
我们对两件事非常认真：了解太空中存在的一切，以及愚人节。今年愚人节，我拉着一位做博士后的朋友做了一些数学计算，以回答汉克和罗曼·马尔斯最近探讨的问题：太空中需要有多少只鸡，我们才会注意到？这产生了一篇科学论文，罗曼，题目叫《智慧的鸡块》，这很有意思。这篇论文里有很多不错的双关语，但我只想为你读一下摘要中的一句话，
from the abstract and one sentence from the introduction. The abstract begins, the lower limit on the chicken density function, CDF, of the observable universe was recently determined to be approximately 10 to the 21 chickens per par sec. For over a year, however, the scientific community has struggled to determine the upper limit to the CDF. So we know the lower limit to the CDF, but what is the upper limit to the CDF? And then the introduction begins as follows, the chicken density function CDF entered the scientific spotlight in a March 2022 episode when a listener of the podcast, dear Hank and John wrote in with a question, the rest of the paper is epic.
以及引言中的一句话。摘要开头写道：可观测宇宙中鸡密度函数（CDF）的下限最近被确定为每秒差距约10的21次方只鸡。然而，一年多来，科学界一直在努力确定CDF的上限。所以我们知道CDF的下限，但CDF的上限是多少呢？接着引言开头写道：鸡密度函数（CDF）在2022年3月的一期节目中进入了科学界的视野，当时一位《亲爱的汉克与约翰》的听众写信提出了一个问题。这篇论文的其余部分非常精彩。
There's so much math. I can't read it. I don't know what any of this stuff means. But the conclusion I don't know what any of this stuff means, but the conclusion is that there would need to be about 10 to the 18th power chickens inside the orbit of the earth for us to start noticing. Wow. That's a lot of chickens, very close to the earth. I know. That's a lot of chickens. I was also surprised.
里面有太多的数学公式。我读不懂。我不知道这些东西是什么意思。但结论是——我不知道这些东西是什么意思，但结论是，在地球轨道内需要大约10的18次方只鸡，我们才会开始注意到。哇。那可是很多鸡，而且离地球非常近。我知道。那确实是很多鸡。我也很惊讶。
Good. I thought it would be, I thought it would be maybe in the hundreds of thousands, but then I was also surprised. Good. I thought it would be, I thought it would be maybe in the hundreds of thousands, but then no, you could put a lot of check in the orphan before it would start to block our view. Oh, that is amazing. Oh, what a great, what a great way to start this episode. We're never gonna, we're never gonna reach those heights, unfortunately. So I hope you enjoyed listening to Dear John and Roman.
很好。我原以为可能是在几十万只左右，但后来——我也很惊讶。很好。我原以为可能是在几十万只左右，但后来不，你可以在地球轨道内放很多只鸡，才会开始遮挡我们的视线。哦，这太神奇了。哦，这是一个多么棒的节目开场方式。不幸的是，我们永远也达不到那种高度。所以我希望你们喜欢听《亲爱的约翰与罗曼》。
Everything after this is gonna be a disappointment. Oh, I love it. All right, so good. You're an expert in architecture and sort of the built world. Okay, yeah, maybe. So I wanted to ask you this question about an apartment. Dear John and Roman, is it a moral failing to find a living roach in my apartment? Does a cockroach show up because I haven't cleaned thoroughly enough as if to lecture me
在这之后的一切都会让人失望。哦，我喜欢。好的，那么很好。你是建筑和建筑世界方面的专家。好吧，也许吧。所以我想问你关于公寓的这个问题。亲爱的约翰和罗曼，在我的公寓里发现一只活蟑螂是一种道德上的失败吗？蟑螂出现是因为我打扫得不够彻底吗？就好像在它被我杀死之前要教训我一样，
before I kill it or do they just wander in because they happen to be in the neighborhood? Do I have to vacuum and scrub every surface now that I have seen this roach not trapped in the metamorphosis? Rebecca. Hmm. I would say it is not a moral failing at all. Agree, but oh, maybe you haven't cleaned thoroughly enough. Oh, I think that's victim blaming. Oh, I think that's victim blaming. No, I just know that it isn't the fault, like, it isn't because you haven't cleaned enough, but if you want to never have a roach again, you should clean like all the time and get rid of like all the crumbs and all the like don't leave dog food out and things
还是它们只是因为刚好在附近就溜进来了？既然我已经看到了这只蟑螂，而不是被困在《变形记》里，我现在必须吸尘并擦洗每一个表面吗？——丽贝卡。嗯。我会说这根本不是道德上的失败。同意，但是哦，也许你确实打扫得不够彻底。哦，我觉得这是在责怪受害者。哦，我觉得这是在责怪受害者。不，我只是知道这不是你的错，比如，这并不是因为你打扫得不够，但如果你想永远不再见到蟑螂，你应该一直打扫，清理掉所有的碎屑，不要把狗粮之类的东西留在外面，
like that. You know, like there's a, that's a, it's a way, it's part of the tactical warfare when it comes to con-roaches, but they will get there everywhere. They're everywhere. They'll be at the very end right before they heat death of the universe. They'll be there. I think they come in, and I take this quite personally because it's an ongoing argument in our family whether the primary reason why we might have bugs or other non-human animals
你知道，这是一种战术，在对付蟑螂时这是战术战争的一部分，但它们会无处不在。它们到处都是。即使在宇宙热寂的最后时刻，它们也会在那里。我认为它们是溜进来的，我对此非常介意，因为在我们家里这是一个持续不断的争论：我们家里之所以会有虫子或其他非人类动物，主要原因是否是因为建筑上的缺陷，这是我坚持的观点，比如有一些小缝隙让蟑螂可以进来。我不知道它们在哪里。我不认为蟑螂是在房子里出生的，你知道吗？嗯。所以我认为那是缺陷。而莎拉坚持认为缺陷在于我太邋遢了。那才是缺陷。
inside of our home is because of a failure in the architecture, which is what I maintain, like that there are little gaps that allow the roaches to come in. I don't know where they are. I don't think the roaches are born inside the house, you know? Well. And so I think that's the failing. And Sarah maintains the failing is that I am filth. That's the failing.
所以我问丽贝卡的问题其实是作为一种代入，想问问你的看法。我不喜欢你的回答。我不认为你能建造一个如此严密的房子，让蟑螂无法钻进来。
And so I was really asking Rebecca's question as a kind of proxy question to you. And I don't like your answer. I do not think that you could construct a house so tight as to not have a cockroach be able to wind its way through it. not have a cockroach be able to wind its way through it. But you could just pick up after yourself, John. You really could. Yeah, no, I mean, I don't want to disagree with you guys. It's just respect you a lot. I think if you have a friend, but you definitely could construct a house, I don't know if that I know you could because like you can you can make a box like you
但你完全可以收拾好自己的东西，约翰。你真的可以。是的，不，我的意思是，我不想反驳你们。我只是非常尊重你们。我认为如果你有一个朋友，但你绝对可以建造一个房子，我不知道我是否知道你可以，因为你可以制造一个盒子，你
could make a box that a a road to get into a house is essentially a very large box. But if you wanted sort of a hermetically sealed you know like white room in which you you know do your viral research or whatever it is yeah you could probably avoid any roaches. That's otherwise. That's what I want. So that I could be as dirty as I want.
可以制造一个盒子，蟑螂进入房子的过程本质上就是一个非常大的盒子。但如果你想要那种密封的、你知道的，像那种你进行病毒研究的白色房间，是的，你可能可以避免任何蟑螂。除此之外，那就是我想要的。这样我就可以随心所欲地邋遢了。
I don't want to do it for viral research. I want to keep smallpox inside the room or whatever. I just want to be able to be the person I want to be in the space I want to be in without risking a roach. Yeah. I want to be in without risking a road. I mean, have you considered putting a box inside the box like your own great idea, your own space? Just wow, if we pitch that idea to Sarah, she'll be like, amazing.
我不想为了病毒研究而做。我想把天花之类的东西关在房间里。我只是想在我想待的空间里做我想做的人，而不必冒着蟑螂的风险。是的。我想要在不冒着蟑螂风险的情况下待着。我的意思是，你有没有考虑过在盒子里再放一个盒子，就像你自己的好主意，你自己的空间？哇，如果我们把这个想法告诉莎拉，她会觉得很棒。
I love it. If you've given them a little box in the corner where he can go and eat, drop all of his crumbs, let him just let him just sneak into his little box whenever he wants to eat. And then he can come out when he's done. He could pile all the dishes in there that he wants to pile. That's fine because that's his box. That's right. It's the only answer.
我喜欢。如果你在角落里给它们一个小盒子，让它进去吃东西，掉落所有的碎屑，让它想吃的时候就溜进它的小盒子里。然后它吃完就可以出来。它可以把所有的盘子都堆在那里，想堆多少就堆多少。那没关系，因为那是它的盒子。没错。这是唯一的答案。
All right. I think we've come to a conclusion, Rebecca. You just need to build a hermetically sealed box inside of your apartment. Dear Roman and John, I know a species is considered native if it is in a certain region due only to natural evolution, but is there a specific amount of time after which a species can be considered native? Is the definition of native species exclusively related to human interference or could animals or other causes, such as natural disaster, displacement species, also make a species non-native. Also, is there such a thing as a plant being considered culturally native? For
好了。我想我们已经得出了结论，丽贝卡。你只需要在你的公寓里建一个密封的盒子。亲爱的罗曼和约翰，我知道一个物种只有在自然进化的情况下存在于某个地区才被认为是原生的，但一个物种在经过多长时间后可以被认为是原生的？原生生物的定义是否完全与人类干扰有关？或者动物或其他原因，例如自然灾害、物种迁移，也能使一个物种成为非原生？此外，是否存在植物被认为是文化意义上的原生？例如，
example, ornstries being a significant part of a Spanish culture despite not being native to Spain? Curious to know more to Chi. That's a really good name, specific sign off more to Chi. It is. It's very good. What do you think? Well, I have a strong opinion about this because I live in Indianapolis, which, depending on your definition of native species, how far back does it go? This is the first question, because if it goes back over 12,000 years, there's no native species to Indiana other than ice, because all of this was covered by a glacier that was like 4,000 feet thick. And maybe there was some moss and stuff, but there weren't any like big, big parties.
尽管橄榄树并非西班牙原生，但它们却是西班牙文化的重要组成部分？很想了解更多。——莫尔奇。这是一个非常好的名字，特别的签名，莫尔奇。确实。非常好。你怎么看？嗯，我对此有强烈的看法，因为我住在印第安纳波利斯，根据你对原生生物的定义，这要追溯到多久以前？这是第一个问题，因为如果追溯到12000多年前，印第安纳州除了冰之外没有任何原生生物，因为这里曾经被厚达4000英尺的冰川覆盖。也许有一些苔藓之类的东西，但没有任何大型生物。
But I am particularly fascinated by this tree called the Ginkgo tree, the Ginkgo below above. And there were no Ginkgo trees in Indianapolis until about 120 years ago. In fact, not to brag, but the first ginkgo tree in Indianapolis was planted by Kurt Vonnegut's great, great grandfather, and I get to walk past it sometimes. So the ginkgo is an invasive species in the sense that it's not native to Indianapolis, except, except until two million years ago, there were ginkgo trees right here along the banks of the way.
但我对一种叫银杏的树特别着迷。印第安纳波利斯直到大约120年前才出现银杏树。事实上，不是为了吹嘘，印第安纳波利斯的这第一棵银杏树是库尔特·冯内古特的曾曾祖父种下的，我有时会路过它。所以银杏是一种入侵物种，因为它不是印第安纳波利斯原生的，但是，直到两百万年前，这里确实有银杏树，就在河岸边。
I remember. Interesting. So it's not a native tree, but it also is a native tree. I think, and I'm interested to get your perspective. Yeah, yeah. But I think that when we think of, like I've been talking to a lot of Horticulturalist people lately because we're planting a bunch of trees around Here to try to even the score. I've caused a lot of you have to you've caused a lot of trees to be cut down for enough and
我记得。有趣。所以它不是原生树，但它也是原生树。我想，我很想听听你的看法。是的，是的。但我认为，当我们想到——我最近一直在和很多园艺专家交谈，因为我们正在这里种很多树，试图弥补损失。我造成了很多——你已经导致很多树被砍伐了，为了——
I think I don't I don't like to get too much into my religious beliefs, but I think that's a significant impediment to getting into heaven. And so I'm trying to plant some trees to even the score a little bit. So the St. Peter won't be so pissed off with me when I get up there. And I've one of the things that I've learned, at least in talking to these these these landscapey people, is that I tend to think of native or non-native as being, in terms of plants as being a dichotomy, like a light switch that's either on or off, but they think of it much more as a spectrum, which I tend to find is the case with a lot of experts,
我认为我不喜欢过多地谈论我的宗教信仰，但我认为这是进入天堂的一个重大障碍。所以我正在努力种一些树来弥补一下。这样当我到达那里时，圣彼得就不会对我那么生气了。我学到的一件事，至少在与这些景观专家交谈时，我倾向于认为植物的原生或非原生是一种二分法，就像一个开或关的电灯开关，但他们认为这更像是一个光谱，我发现很多专家都是这样，
like things that I think of as a layperson, as dichotomous, people who are experts in the field tend to think of as a lay person, as dichotomous, people who are experts in the field tend to think of as spectral. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. Especially with this idea that the ginkgo could be kind of grandfathered in, or Kurt Vonnegut's grandfathered in too, or into our understanding since it existed.
就像我作为一个外行认为是二分法的事情，领域内的专家往往认为它是光谱化的。是的，是的，这很有道理。特别是考虑到银杏可能被视为“祖父级”的，或者库尔特·冯内古特的祖父也一样，或者进入了我们的理解，因为它曾经存在过。
Well, before humans and then was introduced later. I mean, the simple explanation of what non-native is is if humans weren't involved, it's native and if humans were, it's native. But I can see how that would be. It is a little bit of a false dichotomy when it comes to how we operate in the world. And definitely, chance events with animal distribution and whatever, animal law, when distribution could introduce something to an area, which is a stunning achievement, and just because it's not a human, doesn't mean it's not sort of remarkable and sort of unique in it, in the way that it
嗯，在人类出现之前，后来又被引入。我的意思是，非原生的简单解释是：如果人类没有参与，它就是原生的；如果人类参与了，它就是非原生的。但我能看出这怎么会成为一种错误的二分法。当然，动物分布的偶然事件，无论是什么，动物的迁徙，当分布可能将某种东西引入一个地区时，那是一项惊人的成就，仅仅因为它不是人类，并不意味着它不引人注目，也不意味着它在某种程度上是独特的，它
would invade would be exactly the same. So I think this is fascinating. I'm not sure. We're not the only weird species and activity moving things around. For sure. Like when, when, oh my god, I'm going to, this is like a deep pull, so it might be completely wrong. But I love that. That's, hey, that's what this podcast is all about Roman deep, deep cuts that might be wrong, but we're not going to
入侵的方式将完全相同。所以我认为这很迷人。我不确定。我们不是唯一移动东西的奇怪物种和活动。当然。就像当——哦天哪，我要——这是一个很深的话题，所以可能完全错了。但我喜欢这样。嘿，这就是这个播客的全部内容，罗曼，那些可能错了但我们不打算——
be sure. But basically, like up until the point that people realize that, you know, plate tectonics, that the continents moved around. There was a great amount of study to justify the movement of, you know, plant and animal species across these very, you know, like far-flung continents. And it was so advanced, like, you know, like, I'd say recall this story very distant from my education. Like a large book just came out at the very moment, It's I recall this story very distant from my education.
确定的深层内容。但基本上，在人们意识到板块构造论、大陆在移动之前。有大量的研究来证明植物和动物物种在这些非常遥远的大陆之间的移动。而且它非常先进，就像，你知道，我回忆起这个故事，离我的教育很远。就在那一刻，一本大书刚出版，
Like a large book just came out at the very moment right before plate tectonics that was like describing in like in great detail how all the animals and plants made it. It was like the unified theory of movement. And then like a year later, geologists were like, okay, so here's the thing. Yeah, there may be a simple explanation than this like 1400 page theory of everything. And then all of a sudden,
就在板块构造论之前，它非常详细地描述了所有的动物和植物是如何到达那里的。这就像是移动的统一理论。然后一年后，地质学家们说：“好吧，事情是这样的。”是的，可能有一个比这个1400页的万物理论更简单的解释。然后突然之间，
the distribution made more sense because the things were on the land and as it moved along and glaciers came and all that sort of stuff. And so the point being is like, you can get very, I mean, islands are obviously populated by things that feel just as like extreme interventionist as a human, that land on a place, and it is not natural that it lands there, but it is natural that it lands there. And I like to think of myself as not so much separate from nature as a part of nature.
分布变得更有意义了，因为这些东西就在陆地上，随着陆地的移动，冰川来了，诸如此类的事情。所以重点是，你可以变得非常——我的意思是，岛屿显然是被那些感觉就像人类一样极端的干预者所占据的，它们降落在某个地方，它降落在那里是不自然的，但它降落在那里又是自然的。我喜欢把自己看作不是与自然分离的，而是自然的一部分。
Yeah, right, right. Like we think of ourselves as being artificial, even though we are made out of earth and everything inside of us is earth. That's right. We're not that artificial of an intelligence as artificiality goes. You know what your story, and I don't know if you know this
是的，没错，没错。就像我们认为自己是人工的，尽管我们是由地球构成的，我们体内的每一件事物都是地球。没错。作为人工制品，我们并不是那么人工的智能。你知道你的故事，我不知道你是否知道这一点
about me lately, but I like to relate everything to the history of human responses to tuberculosis and your story about plate tectonics reminds me of the story about tuberculosis, which means that I have to tell it. And I'm extremely sorry, but so this guy Robert Koch is the guy who is finally proved to at least to the to the lots of people already knew that tuberculosis was a contagious disease like like lots people in the Americas and and in parts of Asia, but in northern Europe, especially it was really seen as having had to be inherited because it went with all these personality traits, these sort of personality traits we associate with or we associated with
关于我最近的情况，但我喜欢把一切都与人类对结核病的反应历史联系起来，你关于板块构造的故事让我想起了关于结核病的故事，这意味着我必须讲出来。我非常抱歉，但是，这个叫罗伯特·科赫的人是最终证明了——至少对很多人来说，他们已经知道结核病是一种传染病，就像美洲和亚洲部分地区的许多人一样，但在北欧，它尤其被视为必须是遗传的，因为它伴随着所有这些我们与文明联系在一起的个性特征，比如智力和情感敏感性，以及那种约翰·济慈式的人物。所以1881年出版了一本医学教科书，里面有一整章关于所谓的“肺结核人格”。就像，什么样的人必然会得肺结核？这和那个万物理论是一样的，它解释了任何人可能患上的每一个结核病病例，都与这种个性特征有关，或者其他原因。比如童年发生的那件事，或者你父母做了什么等等。然后就在第二年，罗伯特·科赫说：
civilization like intelligence and emotional sensitivity and just sort of being like a John Keatsy type of character. And so in 1881 this medical textbook was published that had a whole chapter on the so-called like a consumptive personality. Like, what kinds of people were inevitably going to get consumption? And it was the same thing where it was like this kind of theory of everything that explained every case of consumption that anybody could possibly get as associated with like this personality trait or else. Like that thing happening in childhood or your parents did this or whatever. And then literally the next year, Robert Coke was like,
“不，它是细菌。我发现了它。这是它的照片。我想是那个。”这使得北欧最大的医学教科书在六个月内完全过时了。我喜欢。我喜欢。这甚至不是一个很好的结核病故事。只是我知道它，我想让你知道。
non-pre assurances bacteria. I found it. Here's a picture of it. I think it's that. Which yeah, like rendered like the biggest medical textbook in northern Europe, totally out of date. Yeah. In six months. Love it. Love it. It's not even that good of a tuberculosis story. It's just that I know it and I want you to know it.
我是那种人，也许我是唯一一个当结核病故事出现时会欢呼的人。就像，它开始在《亲爱的汉克与约翰》中出现。我就想：更多。我简直不敢相信。我仍然无法相信，我无法相信结核病在人类历史的中心，
I'm one of the people who, maybe I'm the one person who cheers when a tuberculosis story, a tuberculosis story. Like, it starts to come up on a dear Hank and John. I'm like, more. I just can't believe it. I still cannot, I cannot believe. I cannot believe that tuberculosis is at the center of human history
以如此戏剧性、明显的方式，从听诊器到牛仔帽，再到新墨西哥州的存在。但我也——以一种更严肃、不那么搞笑的方式——我无法相信这个世纪有4000万人死于结核病，而我一个都不认识。我以为结核病是过去的一种疾病。所以我认为我对结核病的痴迷实际上是关于我对自己作为一个相当投入的人的困惑，当然，当涉及到潜在的健康问题时，我是一个投入的人。然而，我却一无所知。所以它真的重新定位了我对世界的理解。嗯，我喜欢这些东西。好了，让我们进入下一个问题。
in such dramatic obvious ways from the stethoscope to the cowboy hat to the existence of the state of New Mexico. But I also, I cannot, on like a more serious, like less, like funny, haha note, I cannot believe that 40 million people have died of tuberculosis in this century, and I didn't know any of them. I thought that like tuberculosis was a disease of the past. So I think like my obsession with tuberculosis is really about like my confoundedness of thinking
我会尽力的，而且与结核病无关。这是关于一个旧的Instagram账号，罗伯特·科赫做了——不，他没有。好了，让我们进入下一个问题。我会尽力的，而且与结核病无关。这是关于一个旧的Instagram账号，罗伯特·科赫做了。不，他没有。好了，米西问，亲爱的约翰和罗曼，我有一个旧的Instagram账号，几年前忘记了密码，它有很多粉丝，还有几千个帖子（括号里写着：这是一个Finstah）。
of myself as a reasonably engaged person and certainly an engaged person when it comes to potential health problems. And yet, I just had no idea. So it's so like, it's just, it really has reoriented my understanding of the world. Well, I love that stuff. All right, let's move on to another question.
现在我们应该在这里停一下。什么是Finstah？你知道吗？我不知道。好的。什么是Finstah？你知道吗？我不知道。好的。它可能是什么？它可能是金融Instagram吗？就像你用来筹款的？像GoFundMe？Finstah。
I will do my best and not related to tuberculosis. This is about an old Instagram account, which Robert Koch did, did, no idea. All right, let's move on to another question. I will do my best and not related to tuberculosis. This is about an old Instagram account, which Robert Koch did. No, he didn't. All right, Missy asks, dear John and Roman, I have an old Instagram account that I forgot the password to a couple of years ago that has quite a few followers and a couple of thousand posts in parentheses. It was a Finstah.
我的意思是，这对我来说听起来像那样，因为金融科技（Fintech）之类的东西。对。是的，是的。我就是这么想的。好的，我们就假设是那样。这是一个Finstah。我在那个账号上说了一些完全不能反映我今天是谁的话，我对此并不感到自豪。就像，你是通过谎言筹款吗？
Now we should stop here. What is a Finstah do you know? I have no idea. Okay. What is a, what is a Fence to, do you know? I have no idea. Okay. What could it be? Could it be a financial Instagram? Like, were you used to raise money? Like a go fund of me? Fence to.
这不重要。重点是米西说了一些他们不感到自豪的话。我不知道它链接的邮箱，那可能是一个假的，也不知道电话号码。所以基本上它永远存在。如果我变得出名和成功，而这些我14到18岁时的旧帖子被翻出来，我该怎么办？
I mean, that sounds like that to me, because like Fence tech is like financial tech and stuff like that. Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's what I was thinking. Yeah. All right, we'll just assume that. It was a fenced. There are some things that I've said on that account that totally are not reflective of who I am today and that I'm not proud of. Like, did you raise money via a lie?
肯定会被取消资格的，米西。哦，天哪。我的意思是，我真的想说，我很感激我没有这个问题，但我可能有。我认为每个人很快都会有这个问题。我很害怕。我的意思是，我真的很害怕。我也在年轻时说过很多话，米西，不仅仅是18岁。是的，是的，是的。我喜欢那些不能反映我今天是谁的话。对吧？就像我认为那是
It doesn't matter. That's the point is that Missy said things that they're not proud of. I don't know the email, it's linked to, it was probably a fake one, nor the phone number. So basically it's up forever. What do I do if I get famous and successful in these old posts from when I was 14 to 18? the email, it's linked to, it was probably a fake one, nor the phone number. So basically it's up forever. What do I do if I get famous and successful in these old posts from when I was 14 to 18
希望，对吧？是你45岁时不是25岁或15岁时的那个人。绝对。但互联网确实有一种方式，把事情变成——好吧，首先，我想，在某种程度上为成为那个人负责是有道理的。但互联网确实把事情变成了一种——
and stupid get surfaced? Definitely going to be canceled, missing. Oh, God. I mean, I really, I would like to say like, I'm so grateful I don't have this problem, but I might. I think everyone is going to have it soon. I'm terrified. I mean, I'm really scared of it. Like I also said a lot of things, Missy, when I was younger and not just 18. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I like that do not reflect who I am today. Right? Like I think that's that's that's
我对此也有点感觉，出版也是，它把事情变成了一种——时间停止了。我变老了，但那些书没有。就像我长大了，但我的书没有。这就是为什么人们喜欢我的书，因为现在如果我写那些旧书，我会——它们会差得多，但会成熟得多。
the hope, right? Is that you're not the same person at 45 that you were at 25 or 15. Absolutely. But there is a way that the internet sort of like turns things into a, and well, first off, like, you know, like I guess it makes sense to be held accountable for like being that person on some level. But like the internet kind of turns things into a,
你知道，你会思考过这些问题，然后，你知道，完全把它们扼杀在摇篮里，你会思考过这些问题，然后，你知道，我完全把它们扼杀在摇篮里，你知道，是的，是的，是的，完全50页长。对。它会像一本60页的书，你走过去说：“搞砸了。”哪里？整个，整个，整个事情。也许更像是：“嘿，不要做这些糟糕的选择。”
I feel this with publishing to a little bit, it turns things into like a, like time stops. Like I get older, but those a little bit. It turns things into like time stops. Like I get older, but those books don't. Like I grow up and my books don't. And that's part of why people like my books because now if I wrote some of those older books, I would be, they would be way less good, but way more mature.
好的。你为什么要浪漫化这个女孩？别做。成熟点，伙计。是的。所以我会有先见之明，更像一个父亲，这可能会让书变得更糟。但这就是现在的我。我为现在的这个人感到自豪。总之，重点是，我不知道，你如何处理这个问题？因为你已经是一个公众人物很长时间了。是的。你如何处理它？
You know, you would have thought through the problems and then, you know, and like, and totally cut them off at the past, you would have thought through the problems and then, you know, and like, I totally cut them off at the past, you know, like, yeah, yeah, yeah, totally 50 pages long. Right. It would be like a, it would be like a 60 page book where you go like, fuck up. Where? The whole, the whole, the whole thing. Maybe more of like, hey, don't make these bad choices.
哦。我想到的一个故事是，我在巴拉克·奥巴马对阵希拉里·克林顿的民主党提名高峰期发了一条推文。我的推文是2008年的。2008年，我的推文大概是：“我遇到了一个希拉里的死忠粉，这有点奇怪。”因为在那一点上，我
Okay. Why are you romanticizing this girl? Just don't do it. See mature, man. Yeah. So I would be much pre-seer and much more like a dad, which would probably make the books worse. But that's who I am now. And I'm much more proud of this person. Anyway, the point is like, I don't know, how do you deal with this? Because you've been a public person for a long time. Yeah. How do you deal with it?
我总是被巴拉克·奥巴马的人包围，好的。然后八年后有一个Twitter模因，大概是：“嘿，去找到一条八年前的推文并转发它。”你知道。碰巧的是，八年后，希拉里·克林顿正在与唐纳德·特朗普竞选。这条推文重新浮出水面，人们说：“哦，这到底是怎么回事？”哦，不，不，不，不。我当时非常——而且那件事非常无辜，因为当时，它只是像——
Oh. The one story that comes to mind is I did a tweet during the height of this sort of democratic nomination when it was Barack Obama versus Hillary Clinton. And my tweet was 2008. 2008, my tweet was something like, I met a die hard Hillary person and it was kind of weird. Cause at that point I had,
它真的就像这个很酷的——它实际上是一个很酷的异常现象。就像我遇到了一个希拉里的组织者，这有点奇怪，你知道，因为你没有——是的，你不是作为侮辱的意思。这只是——这对我来说有点令人惊讶，来自我所处的那个世界，
I was always surrounded by Barack Obama people, okay. And then there was some Twitter meme, eight years later, that was kind of like, hey, go find an eight-year-old tweet and repost it, you know. And it just so happens, eight years later, Hillary Clinton was running against Donald Trump. And this tweet resurfaced and people were like, oh, what the hell? Oh, no, no, no, no. And I was so, and it was like, the thing was just so innocent, because at the time, it was just like,
有像——因为我认为我的父母在2008年就是这样。他们是希拉里·克林顿的支持者，但不是那种咄咄逼人的。对，对。他们没有敲门。当时，巴拉克·奥巴马有太多的能量。我只是觉得，是的，那就是我所处的——
it was really like this cool, it was actually kind of a cool anomaly. Like I met like an organizer for Hillary, it was kind of weird, you know, like because you didn't, yeah, you didn't mean it as an insult. It's just like, it was kind of surprising to you coming from the world that you came from,
那就是我所处的海洋，你知道，所以——所以总之，这是我对此的温和版本，试图用某种细微差别来解释这一点是非常不舒服的，当看起来好像——你知道，一个即将做出的选择将要摧毁世界时，你确实会这样做，从那以后，我认为随着时间的推移，我作为一种保护措施，已经删除了更多我的个性和我对事物的看法。是的，因为我应该这样做，但我停不下来。我需要停下来，但我停不下来。我确实专注于积极的事情，你知道，我只是希望这不会被误解。我不知道，这只是像——
that there were like, because I think my parents were like this in 2008. They were like Hillary Clinton supporters, but not like aggressive about it. Right, right. They weren't like knocking on doors. And at the time, there was so much energy for Barack Obama. I was just like, yeah, that was what I was,
对，对，我不知道。因为你不想看起来像个盲目乐观的人，好像一切都是金色的。是的，我认为互联网缺少的是希望。而且像——我认为现在世界上最朋克摇滚的事情就是真诚和乐观。是的，我同意。
that was the C I was swimming in. And so anyway. I was just like, you know, like that was what I was the the see I was swimming in, you know, and so so anyway, so this is like my mild version of this and it was extremely uncomfortable to try to explain that and with some kind of nuance when it seemed like, you know, a choice was about to be made that was going to destroy the world, you do, and since then, I think over time, I have removed more of my personality and my takes on things just in general as a protective measure. Yeah, because I should do that, but I can't stop. I need to stop, but I can't stop. And I really do focus on positive things, you know, Like, and I just hope that, that doesn't get taken poorly. I don't know, it's just sort of like,
是的。它们在文化上是如此激进地反主流，完全，完全。所以我认为这就是互联网所需要的。但有时当我这样做时，我想：“我会不会被看作是一个对世界问题一无所知的人？”即使我在写《人类世评论》时，我也非常清醒地意识到这一点，因为我记得我在写引言时，我想：
right, right, I don't know. Cause you don't wanna seem like a polyanna, like everything's golden. Yeah, I think what the internet is missing is hope. And like a kind of, like I think the most punk rock thing in the world right now is earnest earnestness and optimism. Yeah, I agree.
“我希望这是关于这种爱上世界的渴望，但后来我想，哦，但这看起来好像我不关心不公正。”而且我认为地球上的一切都是美丽和神奇的，你知道，当然，这不是我的真实感受。我觉得这是一个复杂的故事。然后，但你——是的。所以我真的在努力寻找解决办法。
Yeah. They're so radically counter cultural, totally, totally. And so I think that is what the internet needs. But then sometimes when I'm doing that, I think, am I going to come across as somebody who's oblivious to the world's problems. Like even when I was writing the Anthropocene Review, I was super conscious of that because I was like, I remember I was writing the intro and I was like,
你如何做到真诚地充满希望，同时又承认现实，不仅是痛苦的现实，还有痛苦的不公正分配的现实？绝对。要彻底、完整地展现自己是如此困难。你的希望是，你知道，如果这个Finstah，无论那是什么，被发现了。它会被当作你所创作和制作的一切的整体。而且，你知道，有一种习惯，当人们发生争论时，更容易攻击一个
I want this to be about this desire to fall in love with the world, but then I was like, oh, but that's gonna seem like I don't care about injustice. And I think like everything's like beautiful and amazing on earth and, you know, and that's not how I feel, of course. Like I think it's a complicated story. And then, but then you're, yeah. So I really struggled with finding the way through that.
更像你的人，他会感受到你的训诫，而不是一个与你如此不同的人，他们不在乎你，他们恨你，或者其他什么，或者你恨他们。所以它创造了一种像E.O.威尔逊山谷那样的思维，进化很难跳过，因为它改变起来太痛苦了。你在那段时间里会被你最喜欢的人伤害，或者其他什么。所以我对此表示同情，希望，好吧，我的意思是，现在每个人都会试图找到米西的Finstah。但听起来这会很难，因为米西不知道与
How do you be earnestly hopeful while still acknowledging the reality, not just of suffering, but also of the unjust distribution of suffering? Absolutely. It is so hard to represent yourself thoroughly and completely. And it's just your hope is that, you know, if this finsta, whatever that is, is discovered. It's sort of taken totality with everything else that you've produced and made. And, you know, there is a habit of, when people get into arguments, it's easier to land a blow on someone
Finstah关联的邮箱名称或密码。但仅此而已。但是，我们难道不应该原谅自己吗？我们难道不应该原谅14岁的孩子吗？绝对。因为他们才14岁？绝对。在某种程度上，我知道这不是一个笼统的陈述，但我们必须承认，这些人的大脑正在形成，他们有能力改变，事实上，他们会并且需要改变。完全。
who is more like you, who would feel your admonishment than someone who is so different from you, they do not care that you, they hate you or whatever, or you hate them. And so it creates a kind of thinking of like an E.O. Wilson Valley, where the evolution is very hard to sort of like skip over because it's so painful to change. You get hurt by the people you like the most during that period of time or whatever. And so, I'm sympathetic to this and hopefully, well, I mean, now everyone's going to be trying to find Mrs. Finsta. But it sounds like it's going to be pretty hard since Missy doesn't know the name of the email address associated with the
当它发生时应该庆祝，而不是那种任务。但我对这种对“取消文化”的反应很敏感，这是一种我从根本上不相信它以人们经常呈现的方式存在的东西，所以这只是那些非常非常棘手的事情之一，我建议的是：走出去，做好人，做一个世界上的好人，这种事情希望永远不会被发现。
Finto or the password. But that's all. But like we have, don't we have to kind of forgive ourselves? Don't we have to kind of forgive 14 year olds? Absolutely. Because they're 14? Absolutely. And to some extent, like I know that I know that that's not a blanket statement, but like we have to acknowledge that these people's brains are getting formed and they are capable of change and in fact will and need to change. Totally.
如果它真的被发现了，故事的一部分就是你成为了这个新的人，这非常重要。是的。在某种程度上，我认为那种“成为新的人并不能抹去你可能造成的伤害，或者你确实造成的伤害”的论点，承认这一点也很重要。这就是围绕所谓的“取消文化”的对话变得非常偏离轨道的一部分原因，因为它需要允许这两种现实存在：人们成长和改变的现实，以及人们可能造成伤害然后成长和改变的现实，而那种
And it should be celebrated when it does happen and not sort of taking the task. But I'm sensitive to the idea of this sort of like reaction to cancel culture, which is a thing I don't fundamentally Believe exists in the way that is presented a lot of the time right and and so it's just one of those really really tricky things and what I would recommend is just like be out there be good be a good person in the world and In this type of stuff will hopefully never be discovered.
伤害仍然是真实的。完全。这真是一团糟。我只是不——我为任何不得不导航它的人感到难过。非常，非常年轻。是的。我的意思是，完全就像——是的，我甚至——当我18岁时，我不记得了。我不记得我当时是什么样了。我不太好。我抽了很多烟。莎拉和我上了同一所高中。所以她有点记得我高中时的样子。她说：“我真正记得关于你的唯一一件事”
And if it ever is, part of the story is that you become this new person, which is super important. Yeah. And in a way, I think the argument that becoming that new person doesn't erase the hurt that you may have caused, or the hurt that you did cause is important to acknowledge as well. And that's part of the way that the kind of conversation around so-called cancel culture, I think, gets really off track, is that it needs to allow for both of these realities, both the reality that people grow and change, and the reality that people can cause harm and then grow and change and that
“就是你身上有一种陈旧的烟味。而且你有点可爱，但主要是因为你看起来像个麻烦。”这和我现在的个性太不同了。就像今天没有人会看到我然后说：“他有点帅，但只是因为他看起来像个麻烦。”是的，那真是一个180度的大转弯。是的，地球上没有人看起来比我更不像麻烦。这就像一条离开了鱼缸的金鱼一样令人畏惧。如果我所处的环境是我茁壮成长的环境，如果真的有这样的环境的话，我显然不在那里。完全。
harm is still real. Totally. It's such a mess. I just don't, I feel sorry for anyone who had to navigate it. Very, very young. Yeah. I mean, exactly like to be, to be a, yeah, I don't even, when I was 18 years old, I don't, I don't remember. I don't remember what I was like. I wasn't great. I smoked a lot of cigarettes. Sarah went to the same high school I did. So she sort of remembers me from high school. And she's like, the only thing I really remember about you
好了。我喜欢我们回答问题非常缓慢，而且数量不多。那是汉克·格林最喜欢的，嘿，《亲爱的汉克与约翰》，但这是我最喜欢的。哦，好。好。好吧，我在这里说。我认为关于这个Finstah会没事的，但公平地说，我们真的不知道什么是Finstah，所以可能不会没事。
is that you kind of smelled really stale smoke. And you were sort of cute, but mostly because he seemed like trouble. And that's like so different from my personality now. Like nobody would like see me today and be like he's sort of hot but only because he seems like trouble. Yeah that's a real 180 right there. Yeah nobody nobody on earth seems like less trouble. That is intimidating as a goldfish that's left its bowl. I'm clearly not in the environment in which I thrive if there even is such a thing. Totally.
我希望我能给你一个全面的、全面的保证。也许这是一个法西斯Instagram账号，也许那样你会有一些麻烦。是的。是的。但是，你知道。我希望没有一整类Finstah，就像我以前听过“Finstah”这个词一样。
All right. I like that we're answering questions very slowly and not that many of them. That's my, it's Hanks Lee's favorite kind of, hey, dear Hankajon, but it's my favorite. Oh, good. Good. Well, I'm here to say. I think it's going to be okay about this Finsta, but to be fair, we don't really know what a Finsta is, so it might not be okay.
好的。我喜欢我们回答问题的方式，非常缓慢，而且回答的问题也不多。这是汉克斯·李最喜欢的“亲爱的汉克和约翰”风格，也是我最喜欢的。哦，太好了。很好。好吧，我想说的是，关于这个“小号”（Finsta），我觉得应该没问题，但平心而论，我们并不真正了解什么是“小号”，所以可能也会有问题。
I wish I could give you like a blanket, blanket reassurance. Maybe it's a fascist insta account, maybe then you would have some problems. Yeah. Yeah. But, you know. I hope there's not a whole genre of fenced, like I've heard the word fenced it before.
我真希望能给你一个全面、彻底的保证。也许那是法西斯主义的Instagram账号，如果是那样的话，你可能确实会有麻烦。是啊，是啊。但是，你知道，我希望不存在那种“围栏”（fenced）之类的流派，我以前听过“围栏”这个词。
And if it was all about fascism, I think I would know that. Yeah, okay. I think it's about fundraising. All right. And if you fundraise under like a false pretense, man, that's not great, but why don't you afford, you were 14, you should apologize, try to make back the money
如果这完全是关于法西斯主义，我想我会知道的。好吧，没关系。我觉得这是关于筹款的。好吧。如果你以虚假的借口筹款，伙计，那不太好，但你为什么不负担呢，你才14岁，你应该道歉，试着把钱还回去
and give it back. Agreed. Kiwa asks, dear John and Roman, someone I love very much is going through a tough grieving process. His girlfriend, the love of his life, suddenly had to move for work and no one knows when she'll come back. He's having a very hard time with her absence and no one knows when she'll come back. Can you call her? Yeah. Yeah. He's having a very hard time. Did she go to space?
然后还回去。同意。Kiwa问，亲爱的John和Roman，我非常爱的一个人正在经历一段艰难的悲伤过程。他女朋友，他一生的挚爱，突然因为工作不得不搬走，没人知道她什么时候回来。他因为她的缺席而感到非常难过，没人知道她什么时候回来。你能给她打个电话吗？是啊。是啊。他非常难过。她去太空了吗？
He's having a very hard time with her absence and can't understand why she has left her where she has gone. What does he call her? Yeah. Or that she will be back eventually. How can I help him in this trying time? Important context, he is a horse. Oh, okay. she will be back eventually. How can I help him in this trying time? Important context, he is a horse. Oh, okay, well there we go. There we go. He's a horse. He's a horse, of course.
他因为她的缺席而感到非常难过，无法理解她为什么离开，她去了哪里。他怎么称呼她？是啊。或者她最终会回来的。在这个艰难的时刻，我该如何帮助他？重要的背景是，他是一匹马。哦，好吧。她最终会回来的。在这个艰难的时刻，我该如何帮助他？重要的背景是，他是一匹马。哦，好吧，原来如此。原来如此。他是一匹马。他当然是一匹马。
He's a horse. Okay. His girlfriend is another horse who went away to training for a while. He doesn't understand English other than his name and the words no and good boy. Doesn't he understand like, what what's the what do you say? Giddy up. Does he understand giddy up? Yeah. What's the other one you say?
他是一匹马。好吧。他的女朋友是另一匹马，去训练了一段时间。除了他的名字和“不”以及“好孩子”这些词，他听不懂英语。他听不懂吗，比如，你说什么？驾。他听得懂“驾”吗？是啊。你说的另一个词是什么？
Halt. Oh, whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Something like that. Whoa, whoa. It's whoa. You say whoa. Yeah. Kewa, you've come to the right place in addition to being fins to experts, Roman and I are clearly equestrian. No, boys. Roman proof. Dangerous. Dangerous. Dangerous, boys. All the written dangerous.
停。哦，吁。吁。吁。类似那样。吁，吁。是吁。你说吁。是啊。Kewa，你找对地方了，除了是Finsta专家，Roman和我显然还是马术专家。不，伙计们。Roman证明。危险。危险。危险，伙计们。所有写的都危险。
Remember about you is the stale smell of cigarette smoke, a little bit of danger, and how you wrote that horse. If there's anybody on earth who looks less comfortable on a horse than I do, I haven't met them. All right, Kewa, we've got a horse problem. This is a bummer. I remember this happened when there was a period in my life where I had two dogs, but one of the dogs died. And it was awful.
关于你，我记得的是陈旧的香烟味，一点点危险，还有你是怎么骑那匹马的。如果地球上有人看起来比我骑马更不舒服，那我还没见过。好吧，Kewa，我们有个马的问题。这真让人沮丧。我记得我生命中有一段时间养了两只狗，但其中一只死了。那太糟糕了。
Like because the other dog was just confused and heartbroken and I felt like, I mean, maybe I was, maybe the Zanthropomorphizing, but I felt like the other dog was like, why did you take away my best friend? Yeah, yeah. And I'm like, they didn't like, they didn't get to like go through the grieving, they didn't like see the death, they didn't, you know,
因为另一只狗只是困惑和心碎，我觉得，我的意思是，也许我是在，也许我在拟人化，但我感觉另一只狗好像在说，你为什么要带走我最好的朋友？是啊，是啊。我就想，他们没有，他们没有机会经历悲伤，他们没有看到死亡，他们没有，你知道，
they weren't like, so they were just, I think they were just confused and, and, and super sad. Yeah. I don't have a solution for this. I just thought it was sad. Yeah. Or alternatively, maybe they view all absences as death, like a kind of like, oh, like a fundamental object impermanence type of thing that they just like. But then sometimes death is followed by rebirth and then other times it isn't. Oh, shhh, shhh, shhh. I mean, the thing is when it comes to this stuff
他们没有，所以他们只是，我想他们只是困惑，而且，而且，超级难过。是啊。我对此没有解决办法。我只是觉得这很悲伤。是啊。或者，也许他们把所有的缺席都视为死亡，就像一种，哦，就像一种基本的客体恒存性的东西，他们只是。但有时死亡之后是重生，而有时却不是。哦，嘘，嘘，嘘。我的意思是，当涉及到这些事情时
is like you can never address the true problem, but addressing the symptoms is pretty good, which is touch your horse, you know, be with your horse, do things with your horse, and there will be fleeting moments in which they will not feel this pain. And that's the, you know, then that's the best you can do. And it probably is the best anyone can do, then that's if that's the best you can do and it probably is the best anyone can do then that's what you should do. That's also probably the best that we can usually do for each other. You know, is is a accompaniment. Yeah. Like can't solve this problem for you because it's not solvable. Yeah. And also you don't need me to solve it because you already know that it's unsolvable. And so my attempts to like solve it or minimize it are not actually what you need. What you actually need is just
你永远无法解决真正的问题，但解决症状是相当不错的，那就是抚摸你的马，你知道，和你的马在一起，和你的马一起做事情，会有短暂的时刻，它们不会感到这种痛苦。这就是，你知道，这是你能做的最好的了。这可能也是任何人能做的最好的了，如果这是你能做的最好的，而这可能也是任何人能做的最好的，那么这就是你应该做的。这可能也是我们通常能为彼此做的最好的事情。你知道，就是陪伴。是啊。就像无法为你解决这个问题，因为它无法解决。是啊。而且你也不需要我来解决它，因为你已经知道它是无法解决的。所以我想解决或最小化它的尝试实际上并不是你所需要的。你真正需要的是
accompaniment. Yeah. Yeah. Just to not be so alone. Yeah. I'm agree. Yeah. I know this chaplain, Vanessa Zoltan, who's also a great podcast host. And she told me a story once about being with somebody in the midst of like terrible, terrible crisis and loss. And this person saying something like like my life will never be the same. And instead of saying like, well, you know, in time, it'll get better. The NASA said, I know. And like just the acknowledgement of the hugeness of what was happening is more of a gift than trying to minimize somebody's experience or some horse's experience.
陪伴。是啊。是啊。只是不要那么孤独。是啊。我同意。是啊。我认识这位牧师，Vanessa Zoltan，她也是一位很棒的播客主持人。她曾经给我讲过一个故事，关于在某人处于极其可怕的危机和失去中时陪伴他们。这个人说了一些话，比如我的生活将永远不会一样了。Vanessa没有说，嗯，你知道，随着时间的推移，情况会好转的。而是说，我知道。就像对正在发生的事情的巨大性的承认，比试图最小化某人的经历或某匹马的经历更是一份礼物。
And the good news is is you get to spend a lot of time with a horse and this seems like a nice horse. Yeah. Yeah, it seems like a good horse with big feelings, which my kind of horse. I like an emotionally engaged horse. Before this Roman and I were talking, and we were talking about how some people hosting this podcast have a bit, our bit ruminative.
好消息是你有很多时间和马在一起，这看起来是一匹好马。是啊。是啊，这看起来是一匹有丰富情感的好马，这是我喜欢的马。我喜欢情感投入的马。在此之前，Roman和我一直在谈论，我们谈论了一些主持这个播客的人有点，有点沉思。
It's been a lot of time thinking, spent a lot of time analyzing, and Roman said the most beautiful thing I've ever heard. And I promised him I was gonna give him a year to use it. Not even, but I can't. Not even 30 minutes. I think I didn't even give him 40 minutes. What he said was, you know, it's really is true
花了很多时间思考，花了很多时间分析，Roman说了我听过的最美的话。我答应他我会给他一年时间来使用它。甚至没有，但我不能。甚至不到30分钟。我想我甚至没给他40分钟。他说的是，你知道，这确实是真的
that the unexamined life isn't worth living, but the over-examined life isn't much better. It's so true. Why do I over-examined life? Why does that horse over-examined life? It's going to be fine. Your girlfriend's coming back, man. Why do I over-examined life?
未经审视的生活是不值得过的，但过度审视的生活也好不到哪去。太真实了。为什么我过度审视生活？为什么那匹马过度审视生活？会没事的。你女朋友会回来的，伙计。为什么我过度审视生活？
The over-examined life also isn't that great. Yeah. Where's all the attention for the over examine life that reminds me that reminds me that today's podcast is brought to you by the over examined life. The over examined life. This Roman Mars original that I stole 40 minutes after he said. This podcast is also brought to you by 10 to the 18 chickens. That's a lot of chickens. That's a lot of chickens. I don't know if that accounts for their spacesuits, you know? But maybe they don't need to have spacesuits.
过度审视的生活也不是那么好。是啊。过度审视的生活的所有关注点在哪里，这提醒我，这提醒我今天的播客是由“过度审视的生活”赞助的。过度审视的生活。这个我从Roman Mars那里偷来的原创，在他说了40分钟后。这个播客也由10的18次方只鸡赞助。那是很多鸡。那是很多鸡。我不知道这是否算上了它们的太空服，你知道吗？但也许它们不需要太空服。
It doesn't say living chickens. It's chickens. Today's podcast is additionally brought to you by Finsta. Finsta, is it financial? I'm not looking it up. I'm never gonna look it up. This podcast is also brought to you by boxes inside of boxes, a place where you can be messing,
它没说是活鸡。是鸡。今天的播客还由Finsta赞助。Finsta，是金融吗？我不会去查。我永远不会去查。这个播客也由盒子里的盒子赞助，一个你可以乱放东西的地方，
eat, and free of cockroaches, or maybe just live in harmony with cockroaches. It's all up to you. This next question comes from Maxi writes, dear John and Roman, recently I was at an ice cream store that has an arcade machine in the corner and I went over to play there and I found six quarters resting on the machine. Can I use those quarters? No one else was around who looked like the quarters were theirs.
吃，而且没有蟑螂，或者只是和蟑螂和谐共处。这完全取决于你。下一个问题来自Maxi，写道，亲爱的John和Roman，最近我在一家冰淇淋店，角落里有一台街机，我过去玩，发现机器上放着六个25美分硬币。我可以用这些硬币吗？周围没有看起来像是硬币主人的人。
With someone coming back for them, did they just leave them there for someone to use? I've had this happen a couple times before, and I can't decide if it's morally right to use them only a little mad, Max. Yeah, use them. I think you got to. Yeah, I think they're there on purpose. I think they're there left for you.
有人会回来拿它们吗，他们只是把它们留在那里给别人用吗？我以前遇到过几次这种情况，我无法决定使用它们是否在道德上是正确的，只有一点点疯狂，Max。是啊，用吧。我想你必须用。是啊，我想它们是故意放在那里的。我想它们是留给你的。
Right. And then maybe if you feel a little weird about using them, like after you have that like four to five minutes of gaming joy that six quarters can buy you these days, you go to the ice cream store and you're like, hey, can I can I get six quarters and you just leave six quarters there for the next person? But I think that I think it's just for you. Yeah. I was recently at a Arcade a pinball thing and there was, I'm a big pinball fan. Yeah, Martin on our show is a huge pinball fan,
对。然后也许如果你对使用它们感到有点奇怪，就像在你享受了六个25美分硬币如今能买到的那四到五分钟的游戏乐趣之后，你走到冰淇淋店说，嘿，我能换六个25美分硬币吗，然后你把六个25美分硬币留在那里给下一个人？但我认为，我认为这只是给你的。是啊。我最近在一个街机厅，一个弹球机，我是弹球的大粉丝。是啊，我们节目的Martin是弹球的超级粉丝，
and I'm a big admirer. I'm just so not good at it that I have not. Oh yeah, you know, like I haven't grabbed onto it as a hobby, but I love it. Right, I'm not good either. I, my, it's very much like my relationship with skateboarding. You know, like I admire the people who are very good at it and I think that it's very beautiful, but then when I play, it's a pretty fast game. But I just love the machines, I love the noises.
我是一个大崇拜者。我只是不擅长它，所以我没有。哦，是啊，你知道，就像我没有把它当作一种爱好，但我喜欢它。对，我也不擅长。我，我的，这很像我和滑板的关系。你知道，就像我钦佩那些非常擅长的人，我认为这非常美，但当我玩的时候，这是一个相当快的游戏。但我只是喜欢这些机器，我喜欢这些声音。
It's like all them. It's like everything that a casino can give you, but it's way less expensive. And so anyway, I was at this pinball arcade and there was a pinball machine with four plays on it. And I think it had four plays on it because the person before me had scored, you know, like 700 billion points or whatever and then just walked away. But I did, I went to the pinball wizard guy who runs the pinball arcade and I was like,
就像所有这些。就像赌场能给你的一切，但便宜得多。总之，我在这个弹球厅，有一台弹球机上有四次游戏机会。我想它有四次游戏机会是因为我之前的人得了，你知道，比如7000亿分什么的，然后就走开了。但我确实，我去找了经营弹球厅的弹球巫师，我说，
hey, this machine has four free plays on it. And he just looked at me like, what's wrong with you? I was like, do you think I, do you think I can use him? And he was like, yeah, yeah, you can use him. Like otherwise, you're going to put a dollar in the machine and then it's going to have five free plays. So I think I think you should just use them. Yeah, you should just use them. Live like that guy, but I love the idea of like leaving six other quarters, but you definitely use the ones that are there and put new quarters on. Totally. 100% critical.
嘿，这台机器上有四次免费游戏机会。他只是看着我，好像在说，你有什么毛病？我说，你觉得我，你觉得我可以用它们吗？他说，是啊，是啊，你可以用它们。否则，你要往机器里投一美元，然后它就会有五次免费游戏机会。所以我认为，我认为你应该直接用它们。是啊，你应该直接用它们。像那个人一样生活，但我喜欢留下另外六个25美分硬币的想法，但你绝对要用掉那里的那些，并投入新的硬币。完全正确。100%关键。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Do you have a favorite quarter? Oh, you mean like in the sort of the state varieties of quarters? Or like maybe it's the original, maybe like that eagle. Yeah. Or maybe like the bicentennial.
是啊。是啊。是啊。你有最喜欢的25美分硬币吗？哦，你是说那种各州的25美分硬币？或者也许是最初的，也许像那只鹰。是啊。或者也许像建国200周年的。
I loved the bicentennial one when I was a kid. I was like, because it was so special. Yeah. But now all the quarters look weird. They do, and it's sort of, I would say I don't at this point, although we, someone pitched us a story once about all the quarters.
我小时候很喜欢建国200周年的那枚。我当时想，因为它太特别了。是啊。但现在所有的25美分硬币看起来都很奇怪。确实，而且某种程度上，我会说我现在没有，虽然我们，有人曾经向我们推销过一个关于所有25美分硬币的故事。
And that is the type of story I would love to know. I would follow that thread, but I don't know if it jazzed. Like everyone else on staff, which is my fry white and sort of make it. But I do think there's a little bit of a problem with all the special quarters is like, if they're all special, like, like, no one is special. Not at all. Yeah. Right. And so you don't get an affinity for that, like, like, like that bicentennial quarter, which showed up every once in a while,
那是我很想知道的那种故事。我会追踪那条线索，但我不知道它是否让员工中的其他人感到兴奋，这是我的Fry White，并试图制作它。但我确实认为所有特殊的25美分硬币都有点问题，就像，如果它们都是特殊的，就像，没有一个是特殊的。一点也不。是啊。对。所以你不会对那个，就像，就像那个建国200周年的25美分硬币产生亲近感，它偶尔会出现，
that you could, you know, like, you attach some meaning to. But I have to admit, I'm, I'm really, in generally, I'm just pretty delighted by each one because I love that type of, you know, sort of, that federal civic symbolism when I love finding out what people choose to represent themselves is super interesting to me. And so, but I don't know if I can't name my favorite,
你可以，你知道，就像，你赋予它一些意义。但我必须承认，我，我真的，总的来说，我对每一个都感到非常高兴，因为我喜欢那种，你知道，某种，那种联邦公民象征主义，当我喜欢发现人们选择代表自己的东西时，这对我来说超级有趣。所以，但我不知道我是否能说出我最喜欢的，
I can barely even picture one of them, but I, you know if I can't name my favorite. I can barely even picture one of them. But I spend time looking at them for sure. I know that you're a flag enthusiast. And one of the things that I like most about Indianapolis, maybe the thing that I like most about Indianapolis is our city flag. Good, good. Doesn't say Indianapolis on it, which makes it rare and valuable on its own, but it's also a really good flag. And then the state of Indiana, and this is a huge surprise, because you would think that it would have a terrible flag, and it has a bad one, but like, it's not nearly as bad as most state flags. I think it's a good, I don't know.
我几乎连其中一个都想象不出来，但我，你知道如果我不能说出我最喜欢的。我几乎连其中一个都想象不出来。但我肯定花时间看着它们。我知道你是一个旗帜爱好者。我最喜欢印第安纳波利斯的一点，也许是我最喜欢印第安纳波利斯的一点，就是我们的市旗。好，好。上面没有写印第安纳波利斯，这使得它本身就很稀有和有价值，但它也是一面非常好的旗帜。然后是印第安纳州，这是一个巨大的惊喜，因为你会认为它会有一面糟糕的旗帜，它确实有一面糟糕的，但就像，它不像大多数州旗那么糟糕。我认为它很好，我不知道。
State flag. It's the, yeah, they could take the word Indiana off of it and then it would be great. But if I'm picturing it right, right, it's the one with the torch and the, you know, and the thing. It is. Yeah, they could sort of a totally dark blue background, golden torch and then some stars around it. It's beautiful. I totally agree.
州旗。它是，是啊，他们可以把“印第安纳”这个词从上面拿掉，那它就会很棒。但如果我没记错的话，对，它是那个有火炬和，你知道，和那个东西的。确实。是啊，他们可以某种程度上完全深蓝色的背景，金色的火炬，然后周围有一些星星。它很美。我完全同意。
It doesn't, it would improve greatly. Just take the word Indiana off of it. But the bones of it, if you did that, are real solid, in my opinion. Yeah. No, I agree. But any Netflix is a great city flag, and it has a, I don't know, it's basically a cross that's centered, and then it has that white star with a round red circle. Yeah. And it's lovely. I just was talking about the Indianapolis flag yesterday. Oh wow. With Michael Greene who runs a thing called Flags for Good.
它不会，它会大大改善。只要把“印第安纳”这个词从上面拿掉就行了。但在我看来，如果你那样做，它的骨架是非常坚实的。是啊。不，我同意。但印第安纳波利斯是一面很棒的市旗，它有一个，我不知道，它基本上是一个居中的十字，然后它有那颗白色的星星和一个圆形的红色圆圈。是啊。它很可爱。我昨天还在谈论印第安纳波利斯的旗帜。哦，哇。和经营一家叫Flags for Good的公司的Michael Greene一起。
And he was telling me about the original version of that. This is about a 70 year old flag, I think, roughly. And the original version of it had the cross off center, like more like a Nordic cross. And oh, and it, like one contest or someone designed it, it won a contest, the designer left the state and it was adopted and he came back to Indianapolis at some point and then the flag was flying and he was like, oh, they were like recentered my flag.
他告诉我关于那个的原始版本。我想这大约是一面70年前的旗帜，大概。它的原始版本十字是不居中的，更像北欧十字。而且哦，它，就像赢得了比赛或某人设计了它，它赢得了一场比赛，设计师离开了这个州，它被采用了，他在某个时候回到了印第安纳波利斯，然后旗帜在飘扬，他说，哦，他们就像重新居中了我的旗帜。
Well, but it should be in the center because I, as I've understood it, is that Indianapolis is a city built on a grid, but the very center of the grid is a circle. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mix a ton of sounds. And so you can actually, not to be too nerdy, but like you, wherever you live in Indianapolis, which is a huge physical city, like one of the physically largest cities in America, you can point to the part of the flag where you live. Like if you live in the northwest side, you can point there. If you live southeast, you can point there and you can sort of use the flag as like I live approximately here as long as you're inside
嗯，但它应该在中心，因为据我所知，印第安纳波利斯是一座建立在网格上的城市，但网格的最中心是一个圆圈。是啊，是啊，是啊。我混合了大量的声音。所以你实际上可以，不要太书呆子气，但就像你，无论你住在印第安纳波利斯的哪里，这是一个巨大的物理城市，就像美国物理上最大的城市之一，你可以指出旗帜上你居住的部分。就像如果你住在西北侧，你可以指那里。如果你住在东南侧，你可以指那里，你可以某种程度上使用这面旗帜，就像我大约住在这里，只要你在
of the city like inside of the beltway. Yeah, yeah. I love flags that are stylized maps like St. Louis has a good one like that. Yes. Yes. You know, that's that shows the rivers converging into this raflutterly that represents the city. I like it. They need to be pretty stylized for them to work in my opinion. Like Indianapolis is a really good example of that. But when they when they work, they work great. I love them. Yeah. And I love the I love the dark blue. I love the light blue of of a Chicago style flag. But I love that I love that the dark blue works for Indianapolis. Yeah. I think so too. I'm that's great to hear. I'm just happy to know that Indianapolis was in your mind in any way.
城市内部，就像在环城公路内部。是啊，是啊。我喜欢那种风格化的地图旗帜，圣路易斯就有一面很好的那种。是的。是的。你知道，那显示了河流汇聚成这个代表城市的图案。我喜欢它。在我看来，它们需要非常风格化才能发挥作用。就像印第安纳波利斯就是一个很好的例子。但当它们，当它们起作用时，它们效果很好。我喜欢它们。是啊。我喜欢我喜欢深蓝色。我喜欢芝加哥风格旗帜的浅蓝色。但我喜欢我喜欢深蓝色对印第安纳波利斯有效。是啊。我也这么认为。我很高兴听到这个。我只是很高兴知道印第安纳波利斯以任何方式出现在你的脑海中。
That's like, we're just happy to be included and have it not be about something horrific. Like, one time I met with the governor and he was like, you know, like, what do you need to be able to do your business effectively? And I was like, I mean, I need you to shut up. It's the main thing I need, honestly. Like I need you to like stop ruining it for me.
就像，我们只是很高兴被包括在内，而不是关于一些可怕的事情。就像，有一次我见了州长，他说，你知道，就像，你需要什么才能有效地开展你的业务？我说，我的意思是，我需要你闭嘴。这是我真正需要的主要事情。就像我需要你停止为我破坏它。
But what I said was like, you know what, governor? Like every time Indianapolis is in the national news, I don't know if you've noticed this, it's bad. Like Indiana never makes news for being awesome. And so what I would love is for you to stop making news. That is a good advice. That's a good advice. Yeah.
但我说的是，你知道吗，州长？就像每次印第安纳波利斯出现在全国新闻中，我不知道你是否注意到了，都是坏事。就像印第安纳从来没有因为很棒而上新闻。所以我想要的是你停止制造新闻。这是一个很好的建议。这是一个很好的建议。是啊。
Stop, stop pumping the brakes on everyone else's attempt to make this a normal nice place to hang out and recruit and work and live. Yeah, well, and let us have a soccer team. Dear Roman and John, I was driving with my sister the other day when we spotted a car wrapped to look like a clownfish. The back of the car said it was for a mobile fish veterinarian, which got us thinking, how do they do surgery on a fish? Do they do it under water? Is there a water mask for the gills, like an oxygen mask for people? Do people even get surgeries on their fish? They didn't teach us this in school. Oh, there you go. I get it. Now I would assume that a mobile fish veterinarian is not performing surgeries, but it's instead being like your fish is good or your fish is not good.
停止，停止阻碍其他人试图让这里成为一个正常的、适合闲逛、招聘、工作和生活的好地方。是啊，好吧，让我们拥有一支足球队。亲爱的Roman和John，前几天我和我姐姐开车时，看到一辆车被包裹成小丑鱼的样子。车后部写着它是为移动鱼类兽医准备的，这让我们思考，他们怎么给鱼做手术？他们在水下做吗？有像人类氧气面罩那样的鱼鳃水面罩吗？人们真的会给他们的鱼做手术吗？他们在学校没教我们这个。哦，原来如此。我明白了。现在我会假设移动鱼类兽医不是在进行手术，而是像你的鱼很好或者你的鱼不好。
And here's some fish medicine. Exactly. But is there fish surgery? And so, surely there can't be. I was very intrigued by this, because I saw this one. I didn't do tons of research today, but I saw the first... No, we didn't do anything about fins test. That's for sure.
这是鱼药。正是如此。但有鱼类手术吗？所以，肯定不可能有。我对这个非常感兴趣，因为我看到了这个。我今天没做大量的研究，但我看到了第一个……不，我们没做任何关于Finsta的事情。那是肯定的。
But I did. I saw this one, and I was like, I'm very curious about this myself, and there's no way I can make a guess. It turns out, yes, there is fish surgery. In fact, no. Yes. I mean, I would say that most of the time that a veterinarian is called in for a fish, it is like to add chemicals or antibiotics
但我确实做了。我看到了这个，我就想，我自己对此也非常好奇，而且我不可能猜到。事实证明，是的，有鱼类手术。事实上，不。是的。我的意思是，我会说大多数时候兽医被叫去给鱼看病，是为了添加化学物质或抗生素
to deal with some kind of Ick or something like that. But for very expensive fish or fish that you're very attached to, probably larger. Like I watched or I saw pictures of a fish surgery and it was something to behold because you are right, like it is not, well, you know, Anna is right. There's kind of a water mask for their kids.
来处理某种白点病之类的东西。但对于非常昂贵的鱼或你非常依恋的鱼，可能是更大的。就像我看了或看到了鱼类手术的照片，这真是令人大开眼界，因为你是对的，就像它不是，嗯，你知道，Anna是对的。有一种给它们鳃的水面罩。
So, so, oh, so they take them out of the water, but they sort of, yeah, they keep the water on them. Yeah, they take them out of the water, I mean, at least the them. Yeah, they take them out of the water, I mean, least the one I saw, they take them out of the water, they have a tube that goes in their mouth that pumps water over their gills so that they can breathe.
所以，哦，所以他们把它们从水里拿出来，但他们某种程度上，是啊，他们保持水在它们身上。是啊，他们把它们从水里拿出来，我的意思是，至少是它们。是啊，他们把它们从水里拿出来，我的意思是，至少我看到的那个，他们把它们从水里拿出来，他们有一根管子插在它们的嘴里，把水泵过它们的鳃，这样它们就能呼吸。
They are anesthetized and they cut them open, they remove their little lump or something, they sown back up and then you have fish surgery. Wow. Humans are remarkable. Amazing. Amazing.
它们被麻醉了，他们切开它们，他们切除它们的小肿块之类的东西，他们缝合起来，然后你就有了鱼类手术。哇。人类真是了不起。太神奇了。太神奇了。
That is amazing. I mean, the things that we can do when we care, exactly, it's incredible. We can perform surgery on fish. We can. Yeah. Yeah. Love it. That's pretty. Yeah. We can perform surgery on fish. We can. Yeah. Yeah. Love it. That's pretty mind blowing.
这太神奇了。我的意思是，当我们关心时我们能做的事情，正是如此，这太不可思议了。我们可以给鱼做手术。我们可以。是啊。是啊。喜欢它。这很。是啊。我们可以给鱼做手术。我们可以。是啊。是啊。喜欢它。这很令人震惊。
I'm sure somebody's gonna send us an email a year from now that's like, actually, we did a study and we found out that fish perform surgery on fish too. And here's our paper full of puns that we published on April 1st. But it's pretty remarkable that humans can do fish surgery. I love it.
我相信一年后会有人给我们发电子邮件说，实际上，我们做了一项研究，我们发现鱼也会给鱼做手术。这是我们发表在4月1日的充满双关语的论文。但人类能做鱼类手术真是太了不起了。我喜欢它。
Incredible. All right. I also wanted to ask you this question about cheese. Okay. From Evan who writes, dear John and Roman, I come to you with a question. I work at a cafe that specializes in wine and cheese, and we have two cheese platters, one for bland tastes, and one stinky cheese clatter. We're talking moldy cheeses. Why do only old people enjoy stinky cheese? Do younger people have more sensitive
不可思议。好吧。我还想问你关于奶酪的问题。好的。来自Evan，写道，亲爱的John和Roman，我带着一个问题来找你们。我在一家专门经营葡萄酒和奶酪的咖啡馆工作，我们有两种奶酪拼盘，一种是给口味平淡的人，一种是臭奶酪拼盘。我们说的是发霉的奶酪。为什么只有老年人喜欢臭奶酪？年轻人有更敏感的
taste buds? People under 35 always go for the bland cheeses, good, a-bree, etc., smell you later, Evan. Yeah, actually. You know, really? Yeah, our taste buds get older and they get less sensitive and it is you are more likely in general to enjoy stronger flavors as you get older because those taste buds just aren't fire in like they used to. That's so interesting. That explains why, if you told me 15 years ago, that a significant portion of my free time would be spent with my mother growing peppers from seed, and then like taking care of them in the garden for six months,
味蕾吗？35岁以下的人总是选择平淡的奶酪，古达，布里，等等，回头见，Evan。是啊，实际上。你知道，真的吗？是啊，我们的味蕾变老了，它们变得不那么敏感了，总的来说，你随着年龄的增长更有可能享受更强烈的味道，因为那些味蕾不像以前那样活跃了。这太有趣了。这解释了为什么，如果你15年前告诉我，我很大一部分空闲时间会花在和我母亲一起从种子开始种植辣椒，然后像在花园里照顾它们六个月，
and then over the next six months processing them into hot sauce, I would have been like, what? My mom lives next door to me. I would have been like, what? My mom lives next door to me. That would have been my first, that would have been my first surprise. For your first surprise. Then my second, I would have been like, and I love it. Wow. And my second surprise would have been that I make hot sauce with my mom. But it's so fun. And also, I love hot sauce, which I didn't 15 years ago. Hot sauce is the best. I love hot sauce too. Oh, oh, I'll send you some. Yeah, I need some green family hot sauce.
然后在接下来的六个月里把它们加工成辣酱，我会说，什么？我妈住在我隔壁。我会说，什么？我妈住在我隔壁。那将是我的第一个，那将是我的第一个惊喜。你的第一个惊喜。然后我的第二个，我会说，而且我喜欢它。哇。我的第二个惊喜是我和我妈一起做辣酱。但这太有趣了。而且，我喜欢辣酱，我15年前不喜欢。辣酱是最好的。我也喜欢辣酱。哦，哦，我会寄给你一些。是啊，我需要一些绿色家庭辣酱。
I don't know if you like our family hot sauce, but you won't complain that it's not spicy. Yeah, so I think the two things working here are, you know, just like the ravages of time and I'm also exposure. I think that if you over time, you try more things. You start to like more things. I think you can refine your palate through exposure and like stink your cheeses and stronger, all kinds of stronger smells and tastes and stuff like that. It's one of the great things about growing older, actually, might be.
我不知道你是否喜欢我们的家庭辣酱，但你不会抱怨它不够辣。是啊，所以我认为这里有两个因素在起作用，你知道，就像时间的摧残，还有接触。我认为如果你随着时间的推移，尝试更多的事情。你开始喜欢更多的事情。我认为你可以通过接触来提炼你的味觉，就像臭奶酪和更强烈的，各种更强烈的气味和味道之类的东西。这实际上可能是变老的好处之一。
I agree. I went to a blue cheese educational evening several years ago. You know, like one of those things where? Sure, where things you do. Yeah, I don't know. Like Sarah was like, oh, I got us tickets to a blue cheese education session. And I was like, great.
我同意。几年前我去参加了一个蓝纹奶酪教育之夜。你知道，就像那种地方？当然，你做的事情。是啊，我不知道。就像Sarah说，哦，我给我们买了蓝纹奶酪教育课程的票。我说，太好了。
And I was very unenthusiastic. This is very standard with me. We're all be like, why are you making me leave the house? It's the only place where I'm happy. Just put me in my hermetically sealed box and allow me to eat Ritz crackers. I don't need any of this fancy stuff. And then I went and it was amazing.
我非常不热情。这对我来说很标准。我们都会说，你为什么要让我离开家？这是我唯一快乐的地方。只要把我关在密封的盒子里，让我吃Ritz饼干就行了。我不需要任何这些花哨的东西。然后我去了，这太棒了。
It was amazing. I learned so much and also I love to experience people's passion. Oh my God. It's like the cornerstone of my entire career, honestly. Yes. It's just like I love people who love things so much that I could watch someone expressing their love for a thing all day long.
这太棒了。我学到了很多，而且我也喜欢体验人们的热情。哦，天哪。这真的是我整个职业生涯的基石，老实说。是的。就像我喜欢那些热爱事物的人，以至于我可以整天看着某人表达他们对某件事的爱。
I love it. Yeah. Yeah. And it doesn't really matter that much. What it is. I mean, as long as it's not like something horn, right? You know, like for me, there's not a huge differentiation between people who are extremely passionate about yarn and people who are extremely passionate about fourth tier English football. It's just the passion. It's the love, it's the fascination. It's the, oh, I forgot to tell you something else
我喜欢它。是啊。是啊。而且它是什么并不重要。我的意思是，只要它不是像什么号角之类的，对吧？你知道，对我来说，极度热爱纱线的人和极度热爱英格兰第四级足球的人之间没有太大的区别。这只是热情。这是爱，这是迷恋。这是，哦，我忘了告诉你别的事情
that's really, really important about the world's largest ball of twine. Yeah. That feeling, it's magical. It really is. It really is. I mean, that's my favorite part of my job is talking to those folks who really light up
关于世界上最大的麻线球，这真的很重要。是啊，那种感觉，它是神奇的。它确实是。它确实是。我的意思是，这是我工作中我最喜欢的部分，就是和那些真正亮起来的人交谈
when they talk about, you know, the simplest things that excite them. It's just so, so, so, so good. Yeah, I could, I can totally enjoy a cheese class, even though I am not a stinky cheese guy at all. But, no, but I would, no, I, I recently went skiing for the first time, which I had no interest in. Yeah. I would know I recently went skiing for the first time which I had no interest in and I and I'm 45 years old. I don't think I'm going to become an expert skier. I mean on a few levels right? Like nobody looked at me and thought like, like, that guy's got a chance at the Olympics. And anyway, I went skiing. I don't know if you've ever been skiing. Are you skiing? No, I mean, I, no, it wasn't part of my life
当他们谈论，你知道，让他们兴奋的最简单的事情时。这真是，太，太，太，太好了。是啊，我可以，我完全可以享受奶酪课，即使我根本不是一个臭奶酪爱好者。但是，不，但我会，不，我，我最近第一次去滑雪，我对此毫无兴趣。是啊。我会知道我最近第一次去滑雪，我对此毫无兴趣，而且我，我45岁了。我不认为我会成为一名滑雪专家。我的意思是，在几个层面上，对吧？就像没有人看着我并认为，就像，那家伙有机会参加奥运会。总之，我去滑雪了。我不知道你是否滑过雪。你在滑雪吗？不，我的意思是，我，不，这不是我生活的一部分
in central Ohio. No, I mean, yeah. You're the same, exactly, right? Thank. Very far away from anything that I, and I didn't just never had any interest in it, but anyway, I went and I didn't, I was, it was fine.
在俄亥俄州中部。不，我的意思是，是啊。你是一样的，对吧？谢谢。离我任何东西都很远，而且我从来没有对它有任何兴趣，但总之，我去了，我没有，我是，这很好。
I liked it. It was great. Whatever, it's good time outside, all that mountains are beautiful, et cetera. But the thing that I loved was my ski instructor, Haley, who loved skiing and like understood it deeply and was passionate about it and needed to like, and needed to share things with me about it that weren't necessarily about like my skiing. It was just about like what makes skiing awesome and interesting and the things that you're able to do on skis that you can't do without them. And I was like, that's the best part of this vacation for me. Totally.
我喜欢它。这很棒。无论如何，在外面度过美好时光，所有的山都很美，等等。但我喜欢的是我的滑雪教练Haley，她热爱滑雪，并且深刻地理解它，对它充满热情，并且需要，并且需要和我分享一些关于它的事情，这些事情不一定关于我的滑雪。这只是关于什么让滑雪变得很棒和有趣，以及你在滑雪板上能做而没有它们就做不到的事情。我说，这是我这次度假最棒的部分。完全正确。
Totally. Getting to like learn from a haley about skiing. Yeah. Yeah. That's, I think that's stuff's's beautiful. Agreed. And it is one of the great joys of listening to 99% invisible. By the way, if you haven't listened to 99% invisible, I'm extremely jealous if you, because you're about to have the best experience. You're about to find out that they're actually, they're actually really good podcasts out there. It's so good.
完全正确。能够像从Haley那里学习滑雪一样。是啊。是啊。那，我认为那些东西很美。同意。这是听99% Invisible的巨大乐趣之一。顺便说一句，如果你还没听过99% Invisible，我非常嫉妒你，因为你即将获得最好的体验。你即将发现实际上，实际上有很好的播客。它太好了。
And but that's one of the joys of listening to it, is that so often you introduced those stories of people's deep love of things, their deep fascinations, and you kind of model how that happens in a way in some episodes, like you allow the listener to experience some of the same magic of falling in love with something. What I like most about the show and the way it changed me
而且，但这是听它的乐趣之一，是因为你经常介绍那些人们对事物深沉的爱，他们的深沉迷恋的故事，你以某种方式在一些剧集中模拟了这种情况，就像你让听众体验到爱上某件事的同样的魔力。我最喜欢这个节目以及它改变我的方式
in the past 13 or 14 years that I've been doing it, and I have to really stress, over the years, my role in what makes the show great has diminished significantly because I have this team of people who make it and are so, so good. And I always say that I'm like the third or fourth or maybe the fifth most important person on any story. But I'm there for every story. But what I love the most in the terms of that sort of like awareness of the world is these designers of our built world and makers of things are solving problems before you even
在过去13或14年我一直在做它，我必须真正强调，多年来，我在使节目变得伟大方面的作用已经显著减弱，因为我有一群制作它的人，他们非常，非常好。我总是说我像任何故事中第三或第四或也许第五重要的人。但我参与了每一个故事。但我最喜欢的是那种对世界的意识，这些我们建筑世界的设计师和事物的制造者在你们甚至还没
have them. They're in a way when you operate in the world, you are in the warm embrace of people thinking about things that you don't even need to bother thinking about. They've handled it for you. And it's changed my outlook of, it makes the world feel so much more caring in general, just by thinking about curb cuts and street lights and you know things like that. It just, it really, really changes my mood when I work on a story, you know, or like write to someone else, work on a story and say, oh, you should move this here. You start to see all the systems that people participate in and strengthen for each other, you know, like from whether that's manhole covers or sewer systems that, you know,
有它们之前就在解决问题。当你在世界上运作时，你处于人们思考你甚至不需要费心思考的事情的温暖怀抱中。他们已经为你处理好了。这改变了我的观点，它让世界感觉更充满关怀，仅仅通过思考路缘切口和路灯以及你知道类似的事情。当我做一个故事时，它真的，真的改变了我的心情，你知道，或者像写信给别人，做一个故事并说，哦，你应该把这个移到这里。你开始看到人们参与并为彼此加强的所有系统，你知道，无论是井盖还是下水道系统，你知道，
we are all working together on some level to make things easier for each other. And that's so lovely. I know. It's such a much better way of thinking about what we're up to as a species. Agreed. It's totally re-oriented my brain doing the show. And so hopefully, you know, you get some of that effect
我们都在某种程度上共同努力，让彼此的事情变得更容易。这太可爱了。我知道。这是一种更好的思考我们作为一个物种在做什么的方式。同意。做这个节目完全重新定位了我的大脑。所以希望，你知道，你得到一些那种效果
when you listen to it too. I certainly do. All right, Roman, it's time for the all important news from Mars and AFC Wimblebin. I'll go first. There is no team in professional football anywhere as far as I can tell on Earth right now that has lost more games from winning positions than AFC Wimbledon.
当你听它的时候也是。我当然有。好吧，Roman，是时候进行来自Mars和AFC Wimbledon的所有重要新闻了。我先来。据我所知，目前地球上没有任何职业足球队比AFC Wimbledon在领先位置输掉的比赛更多。
And today, as we're recording this, good Friday, should I say bad Friday. AFC Wimbledon played Harrogate Town, one of the worst teams in league to favorite to go down, not even be a professional team anymore, won't be able to play them in FIFA next season. Maybe we were winning 2-0, two goals for Mithin Chislett in the 85th minute, five minutes to go, and I thought to myself, maybe we're going to win a football game. But no, no, we gave up a goal, stupid goal, really annoying. And then in the last second of added time, there was a corner kick for Harrogate and everybody, everybody, everybody on the field, everybody on earth knew what was going to happen. You could see it in the eyes of all 11 Wimbledon players. You could see it in the eyes of the 600 fans who'd traveled to Harrogate.
今天，当我们录制这个节目时，耶稣受难日，我应该说糟糕的星期五吗。AFC Wimbledon对阵Harrogate Town，英乙最差的球队之一，被看好降级，甚至不再是一支职业球队，下赛季在FIFA中将无法与他们比赛。也许我们以2-0领先，Mithin Chislett在第85分钟打进两球，还有五分钟，我心想，也许我们要赢一场足球比赛了。但不，不，我们丢了一个球，愚蠢的球，真的很烦人。然后在补时的最后一秒，Harrogate有一个角球，每个人，每个人，球场上的每个人，地球上的每个人都知道会发生什么。你可以在所有11名Wimbledon球员的眼中看到它。你可以在前往Harrogate的600名球迷的眼中看到它。
You could see it in the eyes of the 600 fans who'd traveled the Harrogate. You could see it in my eyes and we gave up a goal when the last kick of the game and tied two to and I can't do this anymore. I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, why am I letting the quality of my life be deeply affected by the exploits of 26 year olds who live far away from it? Why? And then I was like, I went to Sarah and I was like, I, we need to invest real money in AFC Wimbledon. And she was like, no, no, no, that's a non-starter.
你可以在前往Harrogate的600名球迷的眼中看到它。你可以在我的眼中看到它，我们在比赛的最后一脚丢了一个球，以2-2平局，我再也受不了了。我不能，我不能，我不能，我不能，我不能，为什么我让我的生活质量受到住在远处的26岁年轻人的行为的深刻影响？为什么？然后我就想，我去找Sarah，我说，我，我们需要在AFC Wimbledon投入真正的钱。她说，不，不，不，那是不可能的。
And I was like, they need help in their minds. They need mind help because there's nothing wrong with their feet, the problem, and I know what this is like because the problem with me is also inside of my mind. So it's not a criticism, it's just an acknowledgement. And like, I need help inside my mind. And, you know, and Sarah was like, I don't, I think we should probably focus on partners in health, buddy. And that's a good point. That's a good point.
我说，他们需要在他们的思想上得到帮助。他们需要思想帮助，因为他们的脚没有问题，问题，我知道这是什么样的，因为我的问题也在我的脑海里。所以这不是批评，这只是承认。而且，就像，我需要在我的脑海里得到帮助。而且，你知道，Sarah说，我不，我认为我们可能应该专注于Partners in Health，伙计。这是一个很好的观点。这是一个很好的观点。
God is so frustrating. Yeah. Oh, goodness gracious. Mars would never do this to somebody, you know? Mars doesn't have a problem in its head. No, it doesn't. God. It's so difficult.
上帝太令人沮丧了。是啊。哦，天哪。Mars永远不会对某人这样做，你知道吗？Mars的脑子里没有问题。不，它没有。上帝。这太困难了。
It's so difficult right now. Yeah. So anyway, hopefully we won't get relegated. Even though we haven't won an away game in six months, hopefully we won't get relegated. So that's the job at this point. There's only six games left in the season. And hopefully that's hopefully we'll be all right.
现在太困难了。是啊。所以总之，希望我们不会降级。尽管我们六个月没赢过客场比赛，希望我们不会降级。所以这就是目前的工作。赛季只剩下六场比赛了。希望，希望我们会没事的。
What do you have any news from Mars? Is it is a personal question? I guess I don't know anything about the planet Mars. I would say that things are going good in the in the in the Mars household though. So we're going going strong. That's great. That's great. That's the news from Mars. I want it. Like what's the news from Mars? And the news from Mars is that things are all right. You
你有什么来自Mars的新闻吗？这是一个私人问题吗？我想我对火星这个星球一无所知。我会说Mars家庭的情况很好。所以我们正在变得强大。这太棒了。这太棒了。这就是来自Mars的新闻。我想要它。就像来自Mars的新闻是什么？来自Mars的新闻是事情还好。你
know? Yeah. Things are okay. Yeah. We're doing it. You didn't like throw away a 2-0 lead in four minutes to the we worst team in professional football. No, we avoided that fate, but there are many other things that obstacles along the way. Yes, and it's not to say that there are no challenges. The great thing about caring a lot about football is that it's so simple, like life is so complicated and so difficult. And that's the problem with getting too involved in football, is that it just becomes then it's like oh, it's really complicated but if you just watch the games Then then it's so simple, you know, it's a flat field the ball rolls around Sometimes it goes over the line. Sometimes it doesn't it's yeah, you know, it's unimportant and
知道吗？是啊。事情还可以。是啊。我们正在做。你没有在四分钟内对职业足球中最差的球队丢掉2-0的领先优势。不，我们避免了那种命运，但沿途还有许多其他障碍。是的，这并不是说没有挑战。非常关心足球的好处是它太简单了，就像生活太复杂太困难了。这就是过度参与足球的问题，它变得，然后就像哦，它真的很复杂，但如果你只是看比赛，那么它就太简单了，你知道，这是一个平坦的场地，球滚来滚去，有时它越过线。有时它没有，它，你知道，它不重要，而且
In the best possible way. I've been watching a lot more soccer because one of my stepkids is a really fanatic about soccer. Love, loves, loves soccer. Goes to the park by himself for like three or four hours a day to go practice footwork and stuff like that. Wow, that's beautiful. And it's really watching me see him. Is he interested in a trip to South America? I think he would be. Yeah, he would be. We need somebody who will spend three or four hours a day at the park working on footwork.
以最好的方式。我一直在看更多的足球，因为我的继子女之一是一个真正的足球狂热分子。爱，爱，爱足球。自己去公园练习三四个小时的步法之类的东西。哇，那太美了。看着我看到他。他有兴趣去南美旅行吗？我想他会有兴趣的。是啊，他会有兴趣的。我们需要一个每天花三四个小时在公园里练习步法的人。
You're opening it up to 14 year olds. I think you have a, you would have someone, you'd have a taker. But, but I've been amazed by like how, because I hadn't really been to a lot of soccer games, I played soccer as a kid, but I don't think I understood it when I played it. Just to watch the level of thinking for what seems like a bunch of people run around in chaos is really something. Like my appreciation for it has really grown watching this kid.
你把它开放给14岁的孩子，我想你会有人愿意尝试的。但我很惊讶，因为我以前没怎么看过足球比赛，我小时候踢过球，但我觉得我踢的时候根本不懂。看着一群人看似混乱地跑来跑去，其实背后有着极高的思维水平，这真的很了不起。看着这孩子踢球，我对这项运动的欣赏程度真的提高了很多。
Yeah, so it really is an art and it's a kind of brilliance, you know, and when I was a kid, I was taught that there's this hard line between sports and creativity. And as such, I always thought of myself as being just deeply opposed to sports on every level. And it was only when I realized that like, what I was trying to do with stories is not that different from what Roberto Firmino was trying to do with football. That I started to realize, this is a chance to watch people. It's the same thing. It's like the same thing as getting to
是的，这确实是一门艺术，是一种才华。你知道，我小时候受到的教育是，体育和创造力之间有一条明确的界限。因此，我一直认为自己在各个层面上都非常排斥体育。直到后来我意识到，我试图通过故事表达的东西，与罗伯托·菲尔米诺在足球场上试图做的事情并没有什么不同。我才开始意识到，这是一个观察人们的机会。这其实是一回事。就像有机会去
meet somebody who knows everything about the world's largest ball of twang. Yeah, yeah. Or the competing world largest balls of twang. It's that same feeling of like, oh, there's levels to this. Beautiful, beautiful levels. Totally, totally. And I'll compliment or say something completely ignorant and he'll be pretty generous. Like, well, that one wasn't a big deal. This part was a big deal.
见识一下那些了解世界上最大线团球一切知识的人。没错，没错。或者了解那些相互竞争的“世界最大线团球”。那种感觉就像是，哦，原来这里面还有门道。非常美妙的门道。完全同意。我会称赞他或者说一些完全外行的话，他也会很大度。比如，那次没什么大不了的，这部分才重要。
He was a big deal. Yeah, yeah, that wasn't the interesting part. But, you know, I'm glad you noticed that. But that was actually very easy. Yeah. It's knowing to be there. That's hard. And that was always my problem playing soccer,
他确实很重要。是的，那不是有趣的部分。但很高兴你注意到了。其实那很简单。是的，知道该出现在哪里才是最难的。而这一直是我踢球时的问题，
is that I don't have a lot of spatial reasoning. And so the coach would be like, if you just run diagonally, you will get to where they are going, rather than like running behind them, in which case you will never get to them. And I would be like, no, I think the best strategy here is to run run at the person, not where they will be, but where are they now. And then by the time I get there, I'll find that they have moved and I will be shocked every time. Yeah.
就是我的空间推理能力很差。教练会说，如果你斜着跑，你就能到达他们要去的地方，而不是跟在他们后面跑，那样你永远也追不上他们。而我会想，不，我觉得这里最好的策略是直接冲向那个人，不是冲向他们要去的地方，而是他们现在所在的位置。然后等我跑到那里时，发现他们已经移开了，我每次都会感到震惊。是的。
How could I have foreseen this? So. And then you see the people who are really good at it and you're like, oh, they never even have to make a tackle because they're just always there. Like my Sarah played high school soccer and when I played soccer, like in indoor leagues with her and stuff and we would get to the end of a game
我怎么可能预见到这一点呢？所以。然后你看到那些真正擅长踢球的人，你会觉得，哦，他们甚至不需要去抢断，因为他们总是出现在正确的位置。比如我女儿莎拉踢过高中足球，当我和她一起参加室内足球联赛时，每到比赛结束，
and she'd be like, God, you run so much. And I'm like, yeah, but you know where to be. The good ones don't have to run. Exactly. You know, she just me there every time. Well, thank you so much for podding with me. Oh, my pleasure.
她就会说，天哪，你跑得太多了。我说，是啊，但你知道该出现在哪里。厉害的人根本不需要跑。没错。你知道，她每次都出现在那里。非常感谢你和我一起录播客。哦，这是我的荣幸。
I loved it. I'm so excited to be able to talk with you every time we get to chat. I'm such a fan. So this is really cool. Thanks for doing this. This podcast is edited by Joseph Tuna Medish. It's produced by Rosiana Hals. Rohaus, I was joined today by Roman Mars from the podcast 99% invisible, the best podcast you'll ever listen to. Our head of community and communications is Brooke Shotlow. And the music that you're hearing right now and at the beginning of the podcast is by the great Vanarola and as they say in our hometown, don't forget to be awesome. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我很喜欢。每次能和你聊天我都感到非常兴奋。我是你的忠实粉丝。所以这真的很酷。谢谢你参与这次节目。本播客由Joseph Tuna Medish剪辑，由Rosiana Hals制作。今天和我一起录制的是来自播客《99% Invisible》的Roman Mars，这是你听过的最好的播客。我们的社区与传播主管是Brooke Shotlow。你现在听到的以及播客开头播放的音乐是由伟大的Vanarola创作的。正如我们家乡常说的那样，别忘了要活得精彩。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。